forget about the money when you see the
smile on a person's face it's the
greatest job in the world I'm the first
one in the office every day I'm the last
one in the office every day that it's a
passion of mine Real Estate's it's not
just opening up a door and letting
somebody walk around and look at a house
that's not what I do some Realtors do
that I just feel like that's wrong he's
an American real estate agent real
estate investor and reality TV
personality he appears on a television
show million dollar listing on the Bravo
network in 2013 he was ranked as the
number 30 real estate agent in the
country by The Wall Street Journal was
sales of over 200 million dollars his
Josh Altman and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success rule number
one is my personal favorite and as
always if Josh says something that
really really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well enjoy
you
number one you all can tell you got to
love what you do and I love what I do I
love real estate my favorite part about
what I do that I'm so excited every
morning to wake up to is that time when
you get to pass the keys over to a new
buyer of a home and they actually bought
the home and you see the smile on those
people's faces okay that's priceless
you can forget about all the other stuff
forget about the money when you see the
smile on a person's face it's the
greatest job in the world think about it
we help people achieve the American
dream which is owning a home and we get
to be part of that and if you're part of
that those people love you forever you
know you give this great example of how
you were on the treadmill next to Tyler
Perry and you were bold you kind of
talked him up you ended up selling him a
help selling his house but you
approached him and you said are you
ready to sell one of your houses you
already knew that he owned two houses
you knew where they were you know so
isn't that also a big part of this you
have to really do the hard work yeah and
and really preparing yourself to be
lucky putting yourself in situations
where where you can get lucky
where it's not so much luck it's
preparation I tell a story about how I'm
staying inside a line in Starbucks and
I'm not at that Starbucks because I like
coffee I'm at that Starbucks because
that's where all the wealthy people and
all the celebrities in Beverly Hills go
every morning I meet a guy in line in
front of me I end up showing them a
house later that afternoon anybody's a
twelve million dollar house some people
would say that's luck for me it's all
about being in the right place and there
was a reason why I'm there because I'm
an expert in my community and I put
myself in that situation I always say in
order to be a successful salesperson you
got to know your product okay that's the
single most important thing you got to
know it like the back of your hand yeah
otherwise you can't truly sell it and
you got to believe in it you know even
if you don't know it right exactly so I
am very very good and I can look anybody
in this business in the world in the
eyes and say I am an expert at Los
Angeles real estate I study it I know
more than 99.9% of the people out there
okay I flipped houses I financed houses
I sell how
is buying all that stuff so I'm very
confident because I'm very good at what
I do because I'm an expert and I work
very hard to do the work to become the
expert it's not just falling on the lap
it's I'm the first one in the office
every day I'm the last one in the office
every day uh that it's a passion of mine
real estate so is I don't consider it
work but I literally study it they call
me the Rainman real estate there you go
Mexico it's like wow how much is the
house on the 900 block in the flats of
Beverly Hills and you can get be with it
like $100 I can easily although I feel
it's super important these days to be
24/7 okay Alex had said it before buying
a house is the biggest investment of
somebody's life 99 percent of the time
okay that's a big deal we do it every
day we forget how you know nerve-racking
it is and how important it is to these
people so you have to make yourself
available you have to be 24/7 if I'm
making a busy big investment that person
better be available to me and and and
there's a funny joke because it Beverly
Hills in a high-end market you typically
know who you're going against in a
listing appointment in fact I think the
last 10 listing appointments the person
has seen the other five agents the same
exact five agents every time and you
know every once in a while you get that
awkward moment where you're walking out
of a listing meeting and the new agent
is walking in and you give them this
look so it's very important to be
available what I do a secret with that
when all these people are meeting with
these clients and this will be our
little secret a tra you tell the client
listen I want you to call me and the
other people and I want you to see who's
available okay at random times
throughout the day because I know that
these other high-end guys or girls
they're so you know above everything
that they have secretaries and
assistants and buyers agents and this
and that and they don't give their
direct number out and I I pride myself
in being available everybody has my cell
phone I always pick up the call and I
think that's important to people so
that's a little trick that I use I've
always been into this
day the first person in the office and
the last person to leave
I started out like everybody else I
walked up and down the Hollywood Hills
of Los Angeles till there were literally
no souls left on my on my shoes I mean
that's how much I door not and I door
knocked every door and I really kept a
basic a cold called non-stop four hours
a day and I live by schedule and I did
that every day till slowly I pick up one
listing then another then another and
you know next thing you know it's it
starts to get well it starts to get more
fun when you start making money of
course but it I started the same way as
everybody else and and I have people
underneath me that I mentor that I tell
the same thing to you just got to start
just to basics you can't watch million
dollar listing and think that all of a
sudden you're going to make millions of
dollars in real estate you know I've
been in some aspects of real estate for
over a decade now so this didn't happen
overnight this is something that has
been you know worked at non-stop I've
studied the art of negotiation I've
studied how to read people I really
mastered my craft and and I take it very
seriously it's not just opening up a
door and letting somebody walk around
and look at a house that's not what I do
some Realtors do that
I just feel like that's wrong you got to
sell the house you got it you got up
what I like to say sell the dream right
you got to sell the dream most important
is what I like to call surround yourself
with with your dream team hmm
I call Josh Altman's dream team yeah and
it consists of a of a good amount of
support from people that I trust value
their opinion and who I surround myself
with I always say that you are the
average of five people that you surround
yourselves with right you ever hear that
before
yeah totally Jim Rome totally today I
just made that up right um so I think
it's super important to do that so in
real estate for example I have the best
mortgage broker who's available 24/7 for
me and we've worked our way up in the
business together I have you know
everybody from the best title guy in
escrow
and all that so I surround myself with
this team of of people who I can trust
and they can guide me in the right
directions of whatever I do so that's
one way obviously in any business is
just surround yourself with some wit
with people who support you why would
you say to somebody who hasn't found
their work drug yet who hasn't found
that thing that really inspires them
right so the ultimate goal is obviously
to find something that you love to do
because it's not considered work anymore
and it's not about money anymore because
it's all about happiness and waking up
excited to do what you do all these jobs
that led up to that I always try to find
the thing that I love most about each
job and really concentrate on that and
be the best at that you got to go
through a lot of stepping stones in
order to find the place I was I worked
at a funeral home I was an assistant in
the mailroom for a very long time I had
about a dozen jobs which are not so much
fun in order to find the right job and
and that's gonna be everybody's going to
go through that so give it time
concentrate on what you love about your
job and be the best at that I don't care
what you do for a living I don't care if
you're the biggest celebrity in the
world I treat you the same as somebody
you know a newlywed couple who's buying
their first condo for $500,000 I talked
about in my book I you know used to be
field goal kickers so I always say kick
every football the same you treat every
deal the same you treat everybody with
the same respect and I think that's why
people come back to us because we don't
care if you're famous or not they know
that we're the expert away at what we do
and they're the best of what we do so
the most important thing and I tell it
over and over and over and over again
get a mentor okay when I first got into
the business the first few deals that I
ended up picking up were sitting open
houses of more successful agents that
didn't have time to be everywhere I said
listen I'll do anything to help
on your properties and you know they'd
say okay once you sit that this house
that weekend and I'd end up picking up
buyers through them it's it's very
important to have somebody guides you to
be successful again it's it's it's
having someone next to you who's done it
has the the advice that you need can
kind of tell you the the pros and the
cons and what they should be
concentrating on get a mentor it's the
most important thing you know all this
coaching stuff that we do there reasons
why we do this and and it's very very
successful it's been you know it's been
successful for years and years so that
would be the one thing if you can't make
it make sure you call somebody who or
link up with someone who can teach you
the ropes I thought that right now would
be the perfect time to share a customer
service story with you true story a
couple years ago I got a call from a
young lady was all excited she tells me
she's looking for a property and then
she says the word lease our favorite
words as Realtors I'm looking for a
lease ah
you know unless it's an eighty-five
thousand dollar a month lease hello
but I was in a good mood so I took that
call and I said sure I'll help you find
the lease and turns out it was a five
thousand dollar month lease and I took
her around for six months
the term was only a year anyways I like
to finish what I start so I went through
with it found her an amazing place she
couldn't be happier in fact she was so
happy that she called her father that
night and she said dad I got the
greatest place my realtor is amazing
he doesn't care about money at all and
it happened to be that her father was
sitting next to the CEO of his company
and he heard the story and that CEO said
actually I'm thinking selling my
penthouse maybe I should use that guy
sure enough I went in I met the CEO and
I got the listing of his four million
dollar penthouse while I was sitting
that open house on that four million
dollar penthouse because that's my
favorite thing to do a celebrity walked
in and that celebrity walked around and
he checked out that incredible penthouse
and he looked me it looked at me and he
said yeah this is cool do you have
anything cooler I said sure
so I went back to the office and I put
together the list of the coolest
penthouses you could find and I showed
that celebrity around and that celebrity
ended up buying an 11 million dollar
penthouse which broke the record for
Santa Monica so from that lease that
$5,000 a month lease which led to that
four million dollar penthouse sale which
led to that 11 million dollar penthouse
sale and it is the gift that keeps on
giving
on and on and on that is why customer
service is so important to everybody's
business thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because Kevin
or trevone Clack asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you I
mean a profile next
leave it down the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what did Josh say that really
resonated with you the most what rule
was most impactful to you what are you
going to apply to your life for your
business please leave it down the
comments below I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Krypton Co thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book it
really really really really means a lot
to me so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourselves and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon